El Congreso de Perú entró a un receso
que lleva más de cinco horas los
congresistas corrían la redacción de un
proyecto de adelanto electoral que
esperan consiga consenso y también
satisfaga todas las bancadas La idea es
presentar un proyecto para ser debatido
Y tratar de conseguir los 87 votos que
son necesarios para adelantar los
comicios para este 2023 pero al interior
del parlamento peruano las posiciones
son divididas la izquierda sigue
insistiendo en que se convoque a una
asamblea Constituyente para redactar una
nueva Carta Magna esta solicitud es
rechazada por la derecha que a su vez
tiene posiciones muy marcadas por un
lado existen congresistas que apoyan la
iniciativa de la presidenta Dina
boluarte de adelantar los comicios para
este año pero también hay quienes
consideran que las elecciones deben
realizarse el año que viene o sea el
2024 y dentro de la derecha existen las
posiciones que señalan que no se debe
recordar el mandato de los congresistas
porque sería atentar contra la
Constitución que las cosas deben quedar
como están hasta el 2026 y allí recién
realizar los comicios la jornada promete
ser larga y quizás Más allá de la
medianoche los congresistas de una
situación que se espera sea favorable
para solucionar la crisis que vive este
país Francisco y hoy se reunió también
el consejo permanente de la Organización
de Estados Americanos para discutir la
crisis en Perú Cuáles son los
principales puntos de esta resolución
precisamente la comisión permanente de
la Organización de Estados Americanos le
pida Perú priorizar la realización de
elecciones y que sean justas libres y
transparentes el organismo también ha
mostrado su preocupación por el uso
excesivo de la fuerza que han tomado la
policía las fuerzas armadas para tratar
de controlar las protestas y le pide al
gobierno de Dina boluarte que adopte
medidas que sean para poder
controlar poder este sancionar a los
hechos de violencia en en esa línea le
pide al Estado peruano que se respete
los derechos de las personas que han
sido arrestadas y que sean sometidas a
un proceso justo esta resolución de la
Organización de Estados Americanos le
llega a Perú en momentos en que las
protestas continúan y las fuerzas
armadas tratan de desbloquear las vías
según la superintendencia nacional de
transportes hasta esta hora existen 69
puntos de tránsito interrumpidos y 13
vías nacionales afectadas